when all the votes are counted it's
predicted that more than 100 million
Americans will have voted in the midterm
election that includes 39 million people
who voted early Anthony Salman toe is in
the CBS News director of elections and
surveys he's been analyzing the election
results in turnout numbers overnight
you've been with us all night through
the morning can you tell us how the
record turnout helped both Democrats and
Republicans yeah help Democrats because
those turnout boosts helped them flip a
lot of those congressional races that
we've been watching all along the
suburban races areas in and around
cities just outside the suburban areas
where boost from women's in some cases
boost from minority voters help them
flip a lot of the districts that we're
watching but at the same time then you
saw turnout boosts in places in rural
areas outside in states where we had
those competitive Senate races and those
states which tend to be a little bit
more rural well that helped the
Republicans hang on and and maybe been
actually build their lead in the Senate
yeah the president saying he's taking
credit for that for actually rallying in
those states and traveling to those
states as well and talking about issues
like immigration let's talk about
Florida because as always Florida was
something we kept our eyes on all night
when it comes to the turnout
specifically Hispanic turnout how did
that help Republicans well as you can
see on the board here you know Bill
Nelson won the Hispanic vote in Florida
maybe not by as much as he would have
liked to and we were looking at this
last night looking at the patterns down
around miami-dade where you might get a
you would get a larger concentration of
Hispanic voters
Nelson was doing well but not quite
hitting those targets that you would
expect from a Democrat who would be
winning the state and that's why it was
really neck-and-neck
and again those turnout patterns you saw
the larger counties Democrats up but
also in the smaller counties adding up
not as many people but one after another
where you had that Republican turnout
boost to and that was what was helping
us Scott and you had flag to the Cuban
in the Hispanic vote they're crucial in
that state yeah also as well and that's
important to remember down around
miami-dade it's it's Cuban Cuban
American and then as you get towards the
center of the state in and around
Orlando it may be people with Puerto
Rican heritage and and that that's a
break within the Hispanic vote that's
important to note in Florida not to pat
yourself on the back but I'm gonna do it
for you because your polls for the most
part called it right yeah you know
polling is always the subject of a lot
of debate but in this case thank you the
you know the CBS battleground tracker
had the Democrats picking up the house
and with just about as many seats as
they may get somewhere in the two 20s
maybe they get to 230 but what that's a
function of really is that we saw that
turnout boost we thought that if the
Democrats got that turnout boost that
they would be able to flip a lot of
those suburban districts they flip some
blue-collar working class districts to
it was sort of a grab bag a mix as we
went across the country so definitely a
fun night and definitely interesting to
watch him take a couple of days but
breather than on to 2020 starts tomorrow
starts tomorrow all right thank you